Hello Everyone
Today, I'm going to be talking about Electron
Not the technical part.
I will talk about how I built the community for electron
and how the community of Electron helped it grow
My name is Cheng
And I created the Electron framework
I'm currently working at Github
and still working on Electron
So if you have ever created an issue at Electron the repo
you might known me because
I'm usually the guy who closed your issues
So before talking about Electron
I need to talk about its history first
It's still a relatively little project
But the history originated from node-webkit
And if you know about nw.js
node-webkit is the older name of nw.js
So the first edition of node-webkit is the node.js module
It was not production-ready
And then a year later
I joined the development of node-webkit
From that time node-webkit became a framework
that you can develop desktop apps based on it
It was basically the nw.js you know now
And then a year later I started a new project
named atom-shell
And it was open-sourced and
then renamed to Electron
So the story of Electron
started from node-webkit
I joined the development of node-webkit
when I was doing an internship at Intel
At that time, node-webkit was
a perfect project for interns
Because it was interesting
It was open-source
And most importantly
no one was using node-webkit
So it doesn't matter if
an intern messed up with it
So I started as the only developer of node-webkit
And because there were no users,
I could just do whatever I want to the project
And most importantly
no one gave a shit about it so...
My manager didn't care
and, well, the company didn't care
It was just a project for interns
So for me, at that time
the most important thing was
to define what node-webkit should be
So at that time I decided that
I can probably rewrite webkit as
the platform to develop desktop apps
with html and node.js
There were already many projects
doing similar things, but...
apparently all of them were shit
So by working on node-webkit
I can probably create a new generation project
After spending a few months
developing node-webkit
Well, I finally got something
that really worked
My manager was happy with it
because I was
not wasting my time
doing unrelated things
It was a nice result
for interns
But a problem for me
was that it still had no users
I was just spending a few months
entertaining myself
entertaining my manager
It was not real open-source
So I decided to
build a community of node-webkit
and had everyone using it
So the first thing I did
was to build a small community
at that time it was
quite a simple one
I used GitHub issues for bug reports
questions and any type of thing
And there was a mailing list on Google Groups
There were people
who were preferring
the older type of discussion
So after building the community
I started to promote node-webkit
and that's the
most important thing for
new projects, you need to
make people know your project
So at that time node-webkit
didn't have a strong background
even though it was
a project sponsored by Intel
but there was a only an intern working on it
and the project was not
under Intel's GitHub account
It was actually under the account of
an Intel employee
who wrote the first edition of node-webkit
When people saw node-webkit
they were just seeing it's a
simple project developed by no none
So I needed to advertise it
The thing I did was
announcements at different mailing lists
saying that I
created a new awesome project
Just come and use it
some people might be interested in it
they might ask very stupid questions
Well, at that time
no matter how stupid the questions might be
I still needed to answer every one of them
so I probably might have my first user
And another important thing was
I needed to keep publishing a new release
So if I just do one release of the project
and then do nothing later
people would think
this was just a hobby project
If use it I will be fucked up in the end
So the most important thing is to
keep releasing
new versions of the project
After I kept doing so
I finally got my first user
That one was actually quite famous
If you knew
Light Table was an editor
based on real web technology
It was like the fist program project on Kick Starter
So it gained a lot of
It was a very famous project and
it helped node-webkit get lots of attention
So once we had a first user
we might have a second and then more
After that the most important thing became
we needed to keep our first user
How do you keep them?
There's only one thing to do
is just answer their questions
and implement the features they want
and fix the bugs they are troubled with
They are getting support from you and
they will be confident in your project
So more and more people were
using node-webkit and I was
doing a good job of keeping them
Somehow, it started to become famous
So usually when your project becomes famous
you actually have lots of choices
You can ask for sponsorship
from the big companies
who use your project
so you can get money
by working on your own project
Or you can ask some of the contributors
of the project to get into your team
so you have more people working on the project
or you can even start a company or career
based on your own project
probably you can make
huge money from it
One of them was just to
keep your project growing bigger and bigger
As for me, it was a bit different
Ater node-webkit became famous
I did not work on it anymore
Because if you still remember
I did not own node-webkit
I was just an intern that
was doing an internship on the project
Once node-webkit became famous
as an intern, I just lost
the leadership of the project
It basically means I lost
the control of the project
It was not my project anymore
I ended my internship
and started the atom-shell project
atom-shell, if you still remember,
was the old name of Electron
For the first year of Electron
it was unlike the first year of node-webkit
because this time
the development of Electron was sponsored by GitHub
because they were secretly developing
the Atom editor
they thought that node-webkit was
a great platform, but it was not good enough
so they hired me to work on
the new atom-shell platform
At that time, I was still the only developer
for Electron
That was fine because
my only user was Atom editor
and all I had to do was to
make the Atom editor a great product
based on atom-shell
After working on Electron for one year
it was open-sourced together with Atom
and unlike the launch of node-webkit
the launch of Electron was quite easy
because it was a product of GitHub
and there was an open-source project using Electron
the first days of Electron we had
we had lots of stars on GitHub and
we got a lot of new users
just within a few weeks
Since we were not worried about getting new users
the task for me became
I needed to
keep Electron a good project
a project that people would be confident to use
and a project that could be
used for a very long time
To achieve that, I just needed to
keep the project well-maintained
For the community,
this time Slack was quite popular
at that time
It's much better than
the older IRC channel
It's very modern
so we used
Slack as our community channel
we also added some more forums for discussion
And this time, for Electron
I didn't use mailing lists anymore
because it was very hard to use
and for GitHub issues,
I wouldn't allow questions for
when I developed node-webkit
But that is generally bad
when you project became quite big
because there would be many people
asking questions in the issues
and it would distract the development of the project
And to...
make the project well-maintained
one of the important things is to
manage the issues well
Basically, I think
the central idea is to
answer every issue
you don't have to, like...
do support for every people, but
for issues you need to make people know that
this issue has been looked into
so every issue should either be closed
or tagged
If you have an issue that there was no answer
and no response
then hanging there a few months
it would make people feel
the project had been abandoned
And when closing issues
it's important to
let the user know
why the issue is closed
maybe because the issue
was a question
or maybe we have a duplicated issue
when closing issues
you have to at least tell why
you closed it, otherwise people
would be mad about it
and another thing
to give contributors more permission
If a contributor can have
permission to close the issue
they may be more involved into the project
they will think they are part of the project
Apart from issues
another part of managing the project
is to respect the pull requests
Pull requests are the
passage of the new generation
It represents how people like to contribute
to your project
When people create the project to
When people create the pull request to your project
they will expect
you can review their contribution
in time
So my suggestion is to
When there is a new pull request, you should
review them as soon as you can
so people can feel valued
Not everyone knows how your project works
so for most pull requests
you may have
when that happens
you should get them to code review
by commenting the problem
in the code review
People can know your project better
and sometimes you can
When people don't understand your project
code review is a very good way
to tell people the details
But it doesn't mean we need to
merge every pull request
it will harm the project
because code quality
When there are very bad contributions
don't hesitate to reject the pull request
And if a pull request is
not very good but still has value
I suggest doing refactoring of the code
after merging
The last thing to keep
the project well-maintained is to
make contribution easier
There are many ways to achieve that
One of the common things is
to have a "bootstrap" script
which can automatically set up
everything your project needs
Like setting up the building environment
Like synching your submodules
It's also important to have
detailed documentation on the
development of the project itself
You can have documentation
explaining the architecture of your project
and best practice for things
Apart from that, you can also tag
tasks in the issues for beginners
so if someone is interested in
contributing to your project
but has no idea what to do
they can always search for the easy issues
and work on that first thing
And when the project keeps growing
at a certain stage
there will be companies starting to
use your project
For Electron we have Facebook
Microsoft, Slack, and
various startups
building there products based on Electron
And that's really a very good thing
Apart from passion, money is the
only thing that can keep open-souce
projects alive
But people are doing business
based on the project
They will put resources on it
and the project will always
And having company users
can attract more users
because when a big company
is using the project
people would be very confident
the project can be good
and used for a long time
and the company's users usually
contribute a lot back
because they always have their unique requests
they have lots of developers
and usually they are very good developers
and when they need something
they would choose to build the things they want
and then contribute it back
But still, sometimes company users
can actually be bad
For some companies
they're like your busiest users
and when they have something
that needs to be done
you would put those things on
the top of your todo list
and sometimes that can disturb your
original development plan
And for some users
when they found they need to
a new feature of the project
or they want to
refactor the project for another
sometimes they just fork your project
instead of contributing things back
because most
can take a lot of time
and for some companies
they just decide to fork
the project
and forking can be
very bad for open-source
So Electron keeps growing
at a certain stage
it became a huge task
for one developer to maintain
These are the emails I got everyday
So it's impossible for just me
to answer all of the
issues and sometimes the
new pull requests everyday
and I need to take lots of time
reviewing them
And if I put too much
energy into the community
I would have no time
for developing the project itself
which can be very bad
Currently Electron became a team
so now it's not only me working on the project
but have a small team
working on Electron
Some of the team members are from
other teams of GitHub
and we also had a few
new developers
and most importantly
we are still hiring
So at last
if you are interested in joining
the Electron team
you can send email to this
email address
groundwater@github.com
Groundwater is our new manager
of the Electron team
If you are interested in Electron
just follow him
Thank you